[Musica]
come state non ve lo stiamo chiedendo
per educazione e nemmeno per rompere il
ghiaccio allora le formuliamo la domanda
come stiamo noi siamo a pezzi grazie
sono stati anni un po durette
allora vediamo quanti si sentono
pienamente soddisfatti realizzati sereni
perfettamente allineati con la propria
vita non diciamo solo dal punto di vista
professionale
vai senza vergogna
vediamo invece quanti sentono che non ce
la stanno facendo o che il prezzo per
farcela sta diventando un po troppo alto
benissimo noi apparteniamo ovviamente a
questa seconda categoria a questo
secondo gruppo
noi ci conviviamo costantemente con la
sensazione di non farcela
è molto più e molto spesso è più di una
semplice sensazione è una solida realtà
ma allora qual è la buona notizia
è che noi eravamo così pure prima non è
una conseguenza recente semmai la nostra
condizione
adesso sia solo aggravata
sono anni impegnativi sia dal punto di
vista emotivo che dal punto di vista
pratico abbiamo toccato veramente con
mano che cosa significhi essere
multitasking
tu sei a casa in telelavoro che stai
facendo quelle 800 cose in quella con la
imprescindibile
puntuale come le mestruazioni arriva la
citofonata del corriere corriere che
peraltro tu adesso attendi come l'ultimo
dei messia perché è diventato l'unico
momento di mero piacere che ti riservi
sembra un po all'inizio di un film porno
come ti bussa il corriere
adesso sappiamo che molti di voi hanno
già scappato no mentalmente tutta quella
parte iniziale introduttiva quella che
non guarda mai nessuno no per andare a
alla ciccia del film invece noi vi
chiediamo di fare un passo indietro di
ritornare al concetto di multitasking
riporto testualmente da wikipedia che è
la facoltà dove ci siamo specializzati
tutti nell'università della vita
per molti taschin si intende la capacità
di un software di eseguire più programmi
contemporaneamente
passando da un processo all'altro
ma cosa succede se un concetto che si
riferisce alle macchine lo applichiamo
agli esseri umani
adesso noi vi mostreremo che cosa
succede nel cervello di una donna un po
perché è ciò che conosciamo meglio un po
perché culturalmente il concetto di
multitasking si riferisce alle donne
mentre invece di un uomo diciamo che
riesce a fare
una sola cosa alla volta no ok vi
sembrerà di sentire un sacco di
stereotipi ma attualmente i dati ci
confermano che è proprio così che va
ovvero che il lavoro di cura se lo
smazzano ancora le donne
francesca ora sarai il mio cervello è un
gran bel pezzo di cervello grazie lo so
ammirata e signori bella e addirittura
intelligente
la senti la fame è ora di cena e si situ
l'adulta che deve prepararla ok metto su
risottino bruttino non sai cucinare fi
qualcos'altro non è credibile vero è
vero allora metto sul olio per friggere
sofficini ecco meglio controlla le mail
o un attimo lo sguardo si sto guardando
hai risposto al commercialista e mandato
quel documento al fornitore oddio
commercialista c'è una scadenza oggi
guarda che ti ha scritto l'editor
controlla perché urgente sorreggendo
soltanto fria ti chiama dal bagno ho
finito di fare la cacca e amore arrivo
toffano e il corriere è il mio momento
ora che hai mandato già quel pacco in
giacenza due volte
aspetta aspetta ti prego sua figlia
continua chiamarti dal bagno guarda che
se non vai subito ti ricordi cosa è
successo l'ultima volta ci sono scorda
citofono il corriere se ne va no ti
prego spetta ti prego l'olio sta fumando
sul fuoco beato lui e telefono e tu
mamma ecco ci mancava mia madre suo
momento ok senti questo silenzio e tua
figlia che nel bagno ha smesso di
chiamarti perché è passata all'azione
no ti prego ti prego eva non toccare
niente stai ferma
ecco questa è una nostra giornata tipo
ora senza arrivare all'estremo dei
graffiti di feci sui muri e degli
incendi causati per aver messo a
raffreddare una padella di olio bollente
e sotto l'acqua che non si fa vi
vogliamo ricordare
siamo d'accordo che con un
iperstimolazione del genere fare le cose
male sia inevitabile
sono pochissime le persone che riescono
davvero ad essere multitasking ea
portare a compimento con successo ogni
singolo tusk e tutti gli altri c'è chi
ancora non si è arreso e insegue la
performance a tutti i costi con lo
stress e la frustrazione che ne consegue
e poi ci siamo noi noi ci fregiamo di
rappresentare l'altra parte quella di
chi non ce la fa ma non è che non ce la
facciamo e basta è lo rivendichiamo con
fierezza siamo un nuovo modello di
essere umano ilmer dista ilmer distafa
le cose come può e dove arriva mette un
punto siamo talmente orgogliose di
questa nostra filosofia che ne abbiamo
tratto un manifesto
da dove siamo partite siamo partite da
un blog che si chiama mamma di merda
ormai lo sapete e lo so che cosa vi
passa per la mente e quindi sgomberiamo
subito la vostra mente dal dubbio le
nostre figlie sono ancora vive
sì pure troppo
ora quando diventi madre e ai un impegno
di lavoro di piacere che esula dalla
presenza dei tuoi figli succede questo
solitamente tu sei a farti l'aperitivo è
un calice di prosecco in una mano
nell'altra una tartina faticosamente
strappata dalle mani di un altro al
buffet e mentre stai per morderla arriva
quella tua conoscente che
immancabilmente ti chiede
e le tue figlie
dove lei lasciate
ecco a questo punto puoi rispondere in
due modi puoi soffocarti subito con la
tartina oppure puoi dare la risposta che
negli anni abbiamo affinato come la più
performante
le ho lasciate a casa da sole davanti
alla tv con 10 euro per la cena e il
numero dei vigili del fuoco a portata di
mano
a questo punto la conoscente vi guarda
sbigottita perché quasi quasi vi crede
in fondo sei mamma di merda
ma probabilmente invece anziché chiamare
la polizia si farà una risata ecco noi è
da qui che vogliamo partire perché
questa domanda ai padri non la fa
nessuno
[Applauso]
perché quando c'è un padre errante
solitario nella savana ci si aspetta che
a casa con i figli ci sia la vera madre
devota
la figura della vera madre devota e una
gabbia a imprigionarci è la paura del
giudizio
la narrazione dominante sulla maternità
prevede che la donna sia completamente
immolata per i figli e noi donne
contribuiamo alla mistificazione di
questa esperienza c'è un po lo facciamo
credere come quando pubblichiamo sui
social quell'unica foto venuta bene in
cui siamo sorridenti con nostro figlio
in braccio o mettendo completamente che
fino a cinque minuti prima il nostro
figlio ha avuto una crisi isterica
perché voleva mettere le dita nella
presa tu gli hai salvato la vita e
cinque minuti dopo la crisi isterica
l'hai avuta tu perché hai scoperto che
il giorno dopo c'è uno sciopero a scuola
e non sai come fare per andare al lavoro
perché a casa coi tuoi figli dovresti
starci tu è molto significativo che
durante una riunione per un workshop
aziendale in cui eravamo state invitate
a partecipare come relatrici una persona
abbia chiesto ma come mai si chiamano
mamma di merda sono madri assenti
assolutamente no noi facciamo ben di
peggio
a noi è proprio la presenza che ce frega
cioè è l'illusione di poter tenere
sempre tutto sotto controllo
vi racconto questo aneddoto un giorno
dovevo portare la mia figlia maggiore
dal dermatologo
io ho due figlie che chiamo
affettuosamente dei ritmi come le
personificazioni della vendetta nella
mitologia greca
insomma sono molto fiera di me perché
non ho sbagliato il giorno
dell'appuntamento è anche molto stupita
perché sono incredibilmente arrivata in
orario in più ho portato per
intrattenere mia figlia nella sala
d'attesa un libro per prevenire le
occhiatacce che solitamente le persone
mi lanciano quando invece decido di
intrattenerla con il cellulare
la sala d'attesa per me il momento più
bello della giornata non mi sento
neanche in colpa di questo dolce far
niente non come quando sono sul divano
di casa mia che mi guardo una serie tv e
o tutti quei file mentali aperti su
quello che non sto facendo
avete presente no quelle finestre nel
background del nostro cervello che
consumano batteria
ecco no io non mi sto rilassando mi sto
rilassando veramente perché in realtà io
non mi sto rilassando io sto aspettando
il mio turno che purtroppo arriva
velocemente entrò quindi nella nello
studio del dottore con mia figlia le
scopro la schiena la ricerca del neo
sospetto ma niente il neo è sparito non
si trova allora cerco di stemperare con
una battuta
l'attore sarà un buon segno nor lui
niente è impossibile
insomma per farvela breve io sono
arrivata il giorno giusto
dell'appuntamento in orario ho portato
un libro per intrattenere mia figlia
cosa che avrebbe dovuto darmi dei punti
karmici
però ho portato la fine sbagliata
[Applauso]
ma come abbiamo scritto nel nostro
manifesto il mardi smo non si riferisce
solo la maternità ma si può applicare a
tutti i campi dell'esistenza
allora una ventina di giorni fa è stato
il compleanno di mia figlia unigenito
che tale rimarrà
perché nella vita oltre alle ambizioni
serve pure un pezzetto di umiltà cioè è
inutile che sony e la famiglia bradford
seduce la fai manco guna ok
allora per una serie di sfortunati
eventi mia figlia non ha mai festeggiato
un compleanno con tutti i crismi quindi
io che sono una mamma di merda ma sono
sempre una mamma mi voglio veramente
impegnare tantissimo affinché lei abbia
la festa che desidera in giardino
ovviamente piove dopo 180 giorni le
siccità ok dobbiamo rimandare tutti gli
inviti ma comunque quel giorno mia
figlia deve almeno spegnere le candeline
sulla torta
quindi vado a ordinare questa benedetta
torta con l'ultimo unico desiderio che
rimane a mia figlia che sopra ci sia un
piatto
quando la ritiro il pasticcere mi dice i
gatti non mi vengono tanto bene mi
vengono meglio le mucche
e comunque secondo me gli assomiglia a
un gatto
ecco ma ma come ma come come se fa come
come si fa incazzare go uno che ti dice
una cosa del genere
io non ci riesco io non posso nemmeno
per status perché costui è il principe
dei verdi sti è uno che dichiara
apertamente il proprio limite e che
ammette candidamente di non farcela
ma ciò che fa di lui non un artista
semplice ma il sovrano incontrastato di
tutti noi è la soluzione approssimativa
che ha trovato
perché se vogliamo dire che le mucche
gli vengono bene
ma comunque io non ce la faccio quel
giorno ad arrabbiarmi
perché questo episodio e ancor più la
risposta che ci ha dato ci ha fatto
ridere per tutto il giorno cioè ha
scatenato un'ilarità tale addirittura in
mia figlia di 7 anni che era la
festeggiata ma che evidentemente in
questo periodo di convivenza con
siffatta madre ha interiorizzato che la
perfezione non è contemplata
che la perfezione non può essere
nell'ambizione né il risultato a cui
tendere che lo scopo del gioco è come
stai tu
adesso ha solo un po confusa tra gatto
in bocca però insomma sui fondamentali
eccoci a inizialmente pensavamo di
essere solo noi due il problema invece
con il passare del tempo la nostra
community è cresciuto e ora siamo circa
230.000 mehr disti tra i vari social il
94 per cento dei quali sono donne allora
ci siamo interrogati e e ci siamo dette
ma se siamo così tante siamo noi ad
essere inadeguate al metodo o piuttosto
il metodo ad essere inadeguato a noi con
il passare del tempo sono cresciute
anche le le tematiche che abbiamo
affrontato e durante la pandemia abbiamo
deciso di sfruttare la piccola notorietà
che avevamo sui social per renderci
megafono delle istanze che via via ci
venivano sottoposte dalla stessa
community queste istanze sono poi
diventate petizioni addirittura
movimenti di piazza e siamo arrivati ad
essere udite da due ministri è cambiato
qualcosa
allora siamo lontano c'è dal risultato
ok
è stato stimato che a livello globale la
parità di genere verrà raggiunta nel
2.171 mettetevi comode ok
certo non pensavamo disgregarla noi così
è in quattro e quattr'otto ma comunque
ci sono altri dati da prendere in
considerazione molto interessanti
nell'ultimo anno c'è stato un aumento
esponenziale delle dimissioni dal lavoro
un fenomeno che a livello mondiale è
stato chiamato the great racing nation
i casi di burn out sono in un aumento
preoccupante
i giovani si stanno licenziando dal
lavoro non tanto alla ricerca di
condizioni migliori dal punto di vista
economico
ma dal punto di vista del benessere alla
ricerca di un equilibrio sano tra vita
privata e vita professionale cosiddetto
work life balance
ecco
attualmente si sta parlando di una
quinta rivoluzione industriale umano
centrica
a fronte di tutto ciò
potrebbe essere questa applicando il
concetto di inclusività alla
performatività
noi diversamente performanti
rivendichiamo un metodo a nostra misura
alla faccia del multitasking che
evidentemente non sta funzionando
ilmer di smo serve proprio a questo ad
abbassare l'asticella
forse nella società iper performante
siamo a nostro agio ma se così non fosse
se ci sentiamo di pedalare su una
bicicletta con le ruote quadrate e siamo
stufi di provare a spostarla se sentiamo
che non ce la stiamo facendo fermiamoci
e guardiamoci intorno perché sicuramente
non siamo i soli
soddisfare le aspettative altrui non è
farcela e non rende felici
ascoltiamoci
come stiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]